[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
soir les enfants ont chaud nous avons eu
une de ses tantes est dans le ciel j'ai
bien cru que nous allions faire naufrage
je vous l'avais annoncé pas trop temps
très variable allons repasser vous un
peu vous avez l'air d'un bateau la côte
ça m'a aidé son fils et petits abbey
consultant justin on l'échelle et ben
moi je crois que nous nous si ces
trompettes ou soit tu dis que je me suis
trompé nous annonce c'est pas le
problème a dit que j'estime entente son
échelle quand il va faire beau et ben
c'est pas vrai au fait pourquoi est-ce
que justice elle aime beaucoup le lot et
la pluie à l'arrêt les montants et
maintenant la tête à pleuvoir bah c'est
vrai
t je suis pas le seul ça te dire il nous
faudra encore très mal mais c'est oui
nous ne l a pas parlé
le pauvre justin elle s'ennuie
elle veut retourner chez sa maman pas là
bien raison pacal york et qu'elle y
reste
alors justin trop
et les quais
[Musique]
à croire qu'au dr puisses-tu qu'est-ce
qui déconne north ce que tes parents en
tête à grenoble
justin est d'accord pour retourner chez
elle mais elle dit qu'elle est triste
car elle vous aime bien et vous avez été
très gentil avec elle
ok les minières notion te crois tu
reviendras nos voir bientôt comme ça
sera le temps qu'il fera
allons juste une route
je te rappelle chez sa maman pour revoir
les petits allez vite vous coucher enfin
lafarge et shui
[Musique]
admin et cana on n'est pas preneurs
d'orbiel tu es bien chargé nounours
c'est justin patron elle a envie de
retourner chez eux seuls et bien en
route justin nous ne ramenons dans tamar
bonne nuit des enfants allez vite vous
coucher n'oubliez pas de vous laver les
dons effet de pour elle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où
à
[Musique]